david hallyday fils avocat et
confondateur du collectif robe noir et
gilet jaune
bonjour merci d'être avec nous alors
qu'espérez-vous obtenir avec ce nouveau
courrier envoyé au préfet de paris
didier lallement
bonjour alors qu'est ce que le gie l'eau
gelée gilet jaune pardon veulent obtenir
tout simplement une rencontre avec le
préfet de police de paris didier
allemand puisque en fait depuis son
entrée en fonction il interdit les
manifestations dans le centre de paris
près des monuments et près des
institutions politiques
ayez relègue les manifestations dans
l'est de paris
donc il ya urgence en fait à rencontrer
le préfet de police pour les jeunes afin
qu'ils puissent discuter calmement et
convenablement des parcours des parcours
voilà pourquoi on leur interdire en fait
les champs-elysées par exemple quand
leur interdit des rassemblements devant
le sénat alors que le préfet précédent
avait autorisé des manifestations près
des institutions politiques
alem devant la mer l'hôtel des 1000 ou
de biens
voilà ils pouvaient manifester librement
dans le centre de paris donc les
signataires en fait du communiqué de
presse considère que le mouvement des
génies jaune et à raison fait l'objet
d'un traitement discriminatoire de la
part du préfet de police de paris
est-ce que vous avez déjà reçu des
signaux de l'apparat de didier lallement
c'est encore trop tôt
laissé sans doute encore trop tôt mais
on a reçu on n'a pas du tout reçu de
signaux bien au contraire il semblerait
que malheureusement le préfet de police
ne veut pas ouvrir un dialogue puisqu'il
interne est systématiquement toutes les
semaines des secteurs interdits aux
personnes sont venues se revendiquant
jones qui ne verraient véritable
atteinte à leur liberté de circuler et
de et de manifester vous avez chaque
semaine le profil allemand qui prend un
arrêté qui interdit les jets les jaunes
de prendre de tels risques
il ya interdit jaune le passage dans de
nombreuses rues notamment dans le centre
de paris donc il semble pas que
malheureusement que le préfet soit sous
ouvert un dialogue quelconque
lorsque vous dites en vous ajoutant
également que il prend toutes les
semaines excusez moi il prend toutes les
semaines un arrêté qui a interdit en
fait au gilet jaune de se rassembler à
la place du palais royal en vue d'une
manifestation
justement lorsque vous parlez de ces
arrêtés préfectoraux des arrêtés
préfectoraux qui représente selon vous
une atteinte aux libertés individuelles
dans le même temps c'est vrai que les
arrêter ils ont aussi un but c'est à
dire d'éviter tous les débordements et
violence que l'on a pu observer en marge
de ces manifestations des gilet jaune
parfois c'est très souvent même oui bien
sûr mais bon les violences c'était il ya
très longtemps là le moins de gilet
jaune est beaucoup moins massif qu'avant
il a peut être constaté lors des
derniers rassemblements devant le palais
royal qui n'a pas eu de violence tout
s'est bien passé
à partir de là l'argument du préfet qui
indique de manière constante qui a des
éléments ultra violents parmi les jets
les jeunes n'est pas recevable
la preuve en est comme je voulais
indiqué les deux derniers rassemblements
palais royal se sont très bien passées
il n'y a pas eu de violence que ce soit
d'ailleurs de la part des manifestants
ou ce soit de la part de la police
peut-être que pourrait préciser quand
vous faites allusion à des traitements
discriminatoires envers les gilet jaune
de quoi parlez vous concrètement de quoi
s'agit-il
mais tu as essentielle façon c'est clair
il ya vraiment un traitement
discriminatoire de la part du préfet de
police
concernant les manifestations des jeunes
puisqu'on a pu constater que le préfet
de police autorise d'autres
manifestations dans le centre de paris
je me rappelle il ya quelques semaines
il y avait une manifestation syndicale
donc qui était très massives et qui a
fini en fait pas loin
de l'assemblée nationale pas loin de la
place de la concorde donc on nous dise
pas en fait qu' il n'y a pas de
traitement discriminatoire
étant précisé que cette manifestation
syndicale était très massive alors que
les manifestations gilet jaune
aujourd'hui en tout cas sont beaucoup
moins massive que les manifestations
syndicales
alors il ya cette lettre que vous
adresser
au préfet de paris mais quels sont les
autres recours
peut-être judiciaires qu'elles pouvaient
avoir pouvez utiliser aussi pour faire
entendre votre voix
alors évidemment il ya d'autres courent
vous avez le recours de 28 mai
administratif en vue de contester un
arrêté préfectoral
mais sur le fond contestant la légalité
d'un arrêté préfectoral sur le fond ça
prend beaucoup de temps ça prend moins
un an ou un an et demi devant le sommet
administratif vous avez également vous
pouvez saisir la juridiction
administrative en la forme des référés
parce qu'il ya urgence mais
malheureusement ce n'est pas possible
puisque les arrêtés sont les arrêtés
interdisant les manipulations des jeunes
senti le vendredi alors que la
manifestation a lieu le l'homme
donc les délais sont extrêmement serrés
il est donc il est donc obligé jaune
impossible en fait de saisir le tribunal
administratif en urgence merci beaucoup
david alors vous avez de vous avez deux
doigts de recours je vais terminer sur
un mois que vous allez devoir le recours
vous avez aussi des aussi des peines
pénales qui peuvent fait à l'encontre du
préfet de police ou contre x pour actes
attentatoires à la liberté de circuler
et et de manifester en application de
l'article 434-1 cadre du code pénal
merci va vêler des skins pour ces
précisions merci d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle vous en fais
l'avocat de nombreux gilet jaune